[Music]
hello slum TV friends and family welcome
to I'd like to know our Bible question
and answer program it is one of our
favorite programs here for a number of
reasons number one it gives us a chance
to dialogue with you and to do the kind
of Bible research that it takes to make
that possible and number two it gives us
a chance to know what's on your mind in
your heart as we answer your questions
my name is CA Murray I'm in the presence
presence of Pastor Steven bour and
Pastor David
Salazar here at the ministry and um
again as we said one of our favorite
programs I want to encourage you write
in contact us let us know what's on your
mind and your heart and we prom promise
you that we will give you an answer if
an answer indeed can be found from the
word of God you may contact us by
writing to
tvss
mv.org that is TVM tv.org and we will
get to your questions as quickly as we
possibly can we are working our way
through a very impressive stack of
questions as fast as we can but you will
notice that we don't rush through the
questions uh speed is not our goal
accuracy and quality of answer is so
sometimes it takes a few minutes to get
down to the truth and to give you the
due diligence you take the time to write
the question we want to take our time to
answer your question so that you are
thoroughly uh pleased with what we are
trying to do in the name of the Lord by
not rushing through through our answers
so you will you will forgive us on that
sometimes if we take a second or two
longer because we want to be thorough in
our response to you Pastor Salazar if
you would open with prayer then we can
lock right out into today's program let
us pray Heavenly Father we are so
thankful that we are um able to come to
you in prayer and to go through the
throne of grace and boldly come and
request of you to bring us the power of
the Holy Spirit the influence of your uh
inspiration to be able to understand and
to be guided to the truth so that the
things that are written in the word in
your word may actually lead us the
knowledge of Christ and help us to
understand and to live lives that are in
harmony with you so we pray that you
will be with us now help our audience as
well to receive uh your word and be uh
uh help us to be vessels in your service
we pray this in Jesus name amen amen
amen sister Dana from Florida we are
fulfilling a promise to you we try to
squeeze in the answer to your question
uh during the last few minutes of our
last program we were unsuccessful in
doing that so we did make a promise that
we would begin this week's program by
readdressing redressing your
question uh to pastor bour and uh so
we're going to do that now going to read
it all and then we're going to attack it
like we we haven't done this before like
we haven't talked about it before so
we're going to start from the very
beginning dear Pastor bore could you
please explain Paul's meaning in
Colossians 2: 16 and 17 I have had two
experiences where these Bible verses
have been used to prove that the Sabbath
has been changed from Sunday or that God
doesn't require a special day to worship
just as long as we worship him to my
understanding this is not what Paul is
saying but would like to hear your
explanation of these particular verses
and she says thank you so much well
thank you Dana writing from Florida so
Pastor Bo since it was a Gest to you
we'll give you first shot at it and then
we'll sort of chime in uh as we go along
okay maybe I'll just give a general
answer and then we can kind of U you
know answer it Point by
Point uh first of all let's have Pastor
Salasar read uh verses 16 and 17 it says
let no man therefore judge you in meat
or in drink or in respect of a holy day
or in the new moon or of the Sabbath
days which are a shadow of things to
come by the bodies of
Christ okay so basically what we need to
take a look at is what is meant by food
and
drink secondly what about the word
Festival what were the
festivals then we need to deal with the
new moon what were the new moons and
what are the sabbaths referring to here
and then we need to understand what it
means when it says that these
things were a shadow of things to come
but the substance or the body is of
Christ so uh what is meant first of all
by food and drink is that talking about
the food that we eat from our table now
this is very interesting because again
this argument has also been put forth to
say that uh since Christ has gone to the
Cross you can eat anything you want uh
uh any food any drink nothing has to do
uh it does not have to do with with what
you put in your mouth but we know that
is not true uh and one of the ways we
know that is not true is if you look at
the context for Colossians it's talking
about food and drink offerings uh the
context is provided really by the back
end which which talks about these things
being a shadow um if you sit down and
eat a hamburger that's not a shadow of
anything you know so that's not that's
not the issue it's it's the the the food
and drink offerings and you've got to
get the context of the whole new
testament experience to to to work your
way through this point by point I'll
stop there and pick it up in just a
moment Pastor David yeah the like you
mentioned the context of these two
verses really helps understand if we
actually go to verses 14 and 15 and we
read there you know Paul is making the
point for example verse 14 says blooding
out the handwriting ordinances that was
against us which was contrary to us and
took it out of the way nailing it to the
Cross to his cross and having spoiled
principalities and Powers he made us
show them openly triumphantly over them
in it so he's here speaking of the
things that were nailed to the cross the
things that Christ fulfilled if you will
and it's specifically speaking of the
ceremonial laws that were given to the
Jews through Moses
that would be a shadow to of of Christ
of the Messiah that was to come so in
this aspect when it says there let no
man therefore judge you or let not one
command you in keeping the meat
offerings in the drink offerings in
these uh aspects of you know those
festivals or or holid dayss or the new
moons or the Sabbath days that
ceremonial the Sabbath days it's
specifically saying let no one tell you
now that you are to ordain or to keep or
to practice these ceremonial things that
were actually already nailed to the
cross because they were a shadow of
Christ they were a shadow of the Lamb of
God so it's it's really by looking at
the context you understand now that he's
not speaking of the law of the Ten
Commandments of the sday Sabbath is is
nothing to do with that because these
are the ceremonial laws that were nailed
at the cross and that's why Paul says no
one should be telling you judging you or
commanding you to keep those things
anymore the same
expression food and drinks is used in
the book of Hebrews MH where it's
describing the old ceremonial system
versus the new ceremon the new system I
want to read this passage in Hebrews 999
to12 where the old system of sacrifices
and offerings is contrasted with the of
Christ M it says it was symbolic for the
present time that is the present time
when the writer of Hebrews is writing in
which both gifts and sacrifices are
offered which cannot make him who
performed the service perfect in regard
to the conscience yes concerned only
with foods and drinks there's the key
expression the old system had only to do
with food and drinks various Washings
and fleshly
ordinances until the time of reformation
in other words until Christ came because
the next verse says but Christ came as
high priest of the good things to come
now that's important because it says
that they were Shadows of things to come
this is telling us what the shadows of
things to come were MH it has to do with
the coming of Christ yes now in the Old
Testament system you not only sacrificed
animals but you also had Foods you had
grain offerings mhm and you had drinks
which was the libation of grape juice
that was poured over the sacrifices and
so that is what this is referring to
it's not telling you that you can eat
shrimp and you can eat pork and anything
you want you have to take the context
it's dealing specifically with the
sanctuary it's not dealing with the food
that we put on our table now also uh we
find that it it says uh foods and drinks
what is the next thing that it says
holidays or festivals festivals yes so
what what were the festivals I mean of
the old system well you had the the
feast days that were given to the Jews
as days of assembly this is another the
Sabbath of course we're talking about
the you know Feast of Tabernacles you
have the Feast of you know Passover you
had the uh the 11 bread and all these
Feast there were there were seven
actually so these are the feast or
festivals that they had or even they
were considered holy dayss as well
because they were days that were to
commemorate or to remember what the Lord
had done for them in the past some of
them were of course the day of Passover
junipur which was a day of uh judgment
if you will so they had to you know come
humbly before God they were not to eat
and so there were a lot of things that
were just lessons that were taught by
the Lord to them in a practical way that
would Point them to the Plan of
Redemption including of course or
starting with the sacrificial lamb which
is Christ right so it would be kind of
like the Passover unleavened bread first
fruits you know th those trumpets
festivals and all of those pointed in
some way to Christ yes the Passover
pointed to his death un living bread his
burial first fruits his resurrection
Pentecost to the beginning of his
Heavenly Ministry in the Holy place so
uh you know those don't have to be
celebrated anymore because they were
fulfilled in Christ precisely uh and
then it mentions new
moons um
what do we understand by new moons well
you know the if you go to number numbers
20 I mean numbers 1010 for example you
also have there what God is telling them
and I'll read it it says also in the day
of your gladness and in your solemn days
and in the beginnings of your months you
shall blow with the trumpets over your
burnt offerings and over the sacrifices
of your peace offerings that you may be
to you for a memorial before your God I
am the Lord your God so at the beginning
of the month because the the Jewish
system will use the new moons as a
system to keep the months as well so for
them God will recommend them or tell
them that at the beginning of every
month they would to do these the days of
gladness of you know solemn days at the
beginning of your months it says new
moons that they will blow a trumpet and
they will have these burnt offerings
again is dealing with ceremonial
practices that were done in in every
month to to you know to P to to help
them understand their I guess it was for
them to be thankful and be uh come with
Thanksgiving to the Lord and these
things were against ceremonial in a
sense that were just to bring a
sacrifice to present them before the the
the Lord and so um the new moons were
again practices or days of Celebration
that were not necessarily for everybody
it was just pointing to Christ and to
his work yeah the new moons actually was
a a night of no moon it was a dark sky
uh and and of course they were they they
were celebrating uh celebrating that but
all of these looked forward to something
that Christ was going to do so when it
was done it was it was no longer uh uh
part of of of their regime the word
Sabbath sitting like that to my
understanding the seventh day Sabbath is
always annotated it's either in caps
it's Sabbath of the Lord Sabbath of the
Lord your God it it's never written and
just sort of sticking out there like
that like this unfinished partis simple
kind of thing you know it's it's so this
is not talking about uh the Sabbath of
the Lord the Sabbath that's found in the
ten commandments so to to to try to make
this cover that that particular Sabbath
is a little violence being done to the
text because this was not included when
this this was was written you know the
new
moon uh is the actually the first day of
the month mhm uh in the Old Testament
and uh basically some of the Hebrew
feasts began on the new
moon and uh I did some research into
that Hebrew word because it's only one
word and I discovered that 270
times it is translated
month mhm only nine times I was able to
find does it translated new moon and
it's connected with the with the
sacrifices and so um the new moons as
they relate to the
sacrifices yeah no longer have to be
celebrated yes however in the future
we're going to go from month to month
yeah new moon to to eat from the Tree of
Life yes and and the English version the
King James says from New Moon to another
but uh really 270 times that's
translated month as month so it's a
month when you compare Revelation
chapter uh chapter 22 Yeah you find that
it says that there's a tree that
produces its fruit every month every
month correct so at the beginning of
we're going to go at the beginning of
the month and we're going to go at the
end of each week to worship before the
Lord and and so the word sabbaths here
is not referring to the seventh day
Sabbath at all it's referring to the
ceremonial sabbaths that were celebrated
in the course of the year uh and which
pointed to the ministry of Jesus Christ
so you know there's a lot more that we
could say about this but I would
recommend that um you download the app
uh let's see this is Dana download the
app and um you know go to the study
notes that I did on the Hebrew festivals
and you'll have a whole section there
where I deal with the specific issue of
uh whether these are sabbaths uh
ceremonial sabbaths or whether they're
dealing with the seventh day Sabbath
very good well said Well Done uh
sometimes you you you there's surface
reading of the word of God and then
there's in-depth bible study this is an
issue that that begs for in-depth study
rather than just surface reading because
service reading will seem to indicate
that it's saying one thing Bible study
will tell you it's saying something else
so well done Dana good question and
thank you for sending it sending it in
all right now we're here at the The
Squeeze thing again so we we're trying
to get in one more question so maybe
we'll just take a portion of this uh
because this is coming from Tanzania and
then we'll pick it up in our next
question Grayson uh is writing from
Tanzania uh again directed specifically
to Pastor bore uh but we we see it as
being directed to the ministry he talks
about the anchor class that we have
every spring and hopefully one day he
can come from Tanzania and be part of
that um Leviticus chapter 19:2 7 he
wants to know what does that mean what
are the principles in the text and what
are Ellen White's comments on that text
so let's run to Leviticus chapter 19 and
pick up verse 27 Pastor do you have it I
do oh good and it says you shall not
round the corners of your heads neither
shalt thou Mar the corners of thy
beard so this is a text that is dealing
with um your hair and your beer you
should not round
them the corners of your beer neither of
your
heads so what are the principles in this
verse well the bottom line is that there
uh Leviticus 19 has a series of
practices that are mentioned in the
chapter and what I believe is that many
of these uh practices were being
performed by the Pagan nations in Canaan
mhm God gave a lot of counsel to Israel
about not doing what the Pagan religions
did in Canaan MH and evidently uh the
the Pagan nations were doing some of
these things and so God says you have to
be totally distinct from these nations
yeah don't do the same practices as them
so uh you know I don't think that uh
this
counil would fit exactly today unless
it's a practice that is linked with an
apostate religion or a Pagan religion or
unless it applies in the local context
in which we're living now if you read
the NIV of that it says do not cut uh
New Living do not trim um then as you
got round round round uh new King James
do not shave um do not round not I
remember when I was uh doing a meeting
in um in Jamaica years ago I don't know
if they still do this but um they
encouraged a lot of the people who were
coming out of the Rastafarian religion
into adventism to shave their dreads uh
to shave their their dreadlocks and some
people took issue with that they really
didn't want to because it takes a long
time to years to get that they didn't
want to cut it off just just like that
um but they thought that there's the
linkage between dreadlock wearing and
advertis was was was not fair was just
too much linked with that religious
practice and so they they they did it I
don't know this is years ago so I don't
know if they they still do or not but I
agree with Pastor bour they they didn't
want to have this this representation of
a of a pagan practice as part of of what
they were doing and that's important to
I'm sorry to just to remember that you
know the Lord It's interested in
providing the his people and
understanding of how to live in ways
where they represent the Lord and a lot
of the the counsels that we have
throughout the Bible in regards to you
know the length of the hair or U you
know not not shaving of your head it
it's it's a lot to do with the fact that
he does not want his people to be
confused with hidden with those who are
practicing aspects of of paganism or
following after the customs of the of
the world Wicked Customs of the world so
it's in this case as as you well
mentioned it's in regards to the Heathen
nations of that time that they had these
practices that God said I don't want you
to appear you know as one that follows
those Heathen
practices yeah I think one of the
principles that that we get from this is
uh the use of tattoos these
days you know tattoos that disfigure the
body God did not make the body to be a
billboard MH
exactly and so to disfigure the temple
of God that would be a principle today
if you take this principle mhm and you
apply it in this context text absolutely
I think that it would apply to to things
that attract attention to ourselves and
things that are linked with with Pagan
culture which basically to a great
degree uh the secular culture of the
United States is Pagan absolutely it's
becoming more and more Pagan each day
yeah uh so I think the principle would
be uh don't disfigure your body you know
we would be opposed to things like
abortion uh you know all of those all of
those things would be forbidden in
principle which is don't copy the the
secular practices that disfigure the
body or disfigure the message of God
yeah yes um to to build on that just a
little bit um when you come to the Lord
you are a representative of Christ so
that means that you are going to by
necessity have to stop doing some things
that would that would give the idea in
some other people's minds that you're
part of another culture
uh take for instance uh the rainbow well
God showed knowah the rainbow sign won't
be water fire next time right uh so if
you walk around with a rainbow today
that's not what they're thinking right
you know they're not thinking that so
you are going to have to be very
judicious in how you use that because
that will put the wrong thought in
people's Mind by using that the
rainbow's a beautiful thing but it has
other connotation now so you got to be
very very careful how you how you use it
excellent example example yeah really
really good example absolutely um any
more on this I don't want to try to get
into he's got one two three questions
here and um I'm trying not to you got
the 24 Elders is going to take a minute
I think I think uh just to conclude this
question I think that what we need to do
is we need to learn to think in the on
the basis of principles yes well rather
than lists you know uh for example when
it comes to the Sabbath in the Bible
there's no list about what you can do
and not do on Sabbath it's a very small
list don't cook you know but the but the
Bible gives a don't don't cook don't
pick up uh you know wood and light a
fire just three or four specific things
that I mentioned in the bible not to do
on the Sabbath but the principle is in
Isaiah 58 where it says take away your
foot from doing your will my holy day
now we have to learn to follow what our
conscience is whether we are applying
the principle to specific things like
for example do we watch secular
television on Sabbath the Bible doesn't
say you can't but the principle says
that you're not going to do your own
ways yes or your own will on the Sabbath
day so we take the
principle and through the power of the
Holy Spirit we say is this proper is
this not proper by applying the
principle yes when we do that we don't
fall into legalism where the RAB has
made a thousand regulations about what
you can do and not do on the Sabbath God
has given us a conscience and he's given
us the principle and we need to learn
how to apply the principle amen and amen
amen and amen all righty um we're down
to the last several sections this is
very very very good I think applying the
principle and and and praying about
things too I know in in a a program
before you guys dealt with someone asked
a question about having intimate
relations on the Sabbath you know there
there are principles and and the Bible
says doing thy pleasure on my holy day
so you've got to you've got to put it
and the thing is a desire to do the will
of God if you're fighting against it
you're always going to have a problem
with it but if you are accepting God's
Will and surrendering to God's will some
of these questions become just a bit
easier amen as we put it in that context
again this has been enlightening for us
we hope it has been enlightening for you
our time has fast slipped into eternity
allow me in closing to wish you both
Grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you again
soon bye-bye and and God bless
[Music]